-Fox News reportedly has
a dossier
of alleged dirt,
aka an oppo file,
on Tucker Carlson,
amid their messy separation
from the recently ousted host,
as speculation runs rampant
about what, exactly, led
to Carlson's abrupt exit.
Meanwhile, Fox itself is
basically acting like Carlson,
who was, until two days ago,
one of their biggest stars,
never even existed.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Whenever something really big
happens that involves Fox News,
the last people to hear about it
are usually the people
who watch Fox News.
[ Laughter ]
The network tends to hide news
about itself
from its own viewers.
Last night there were probably
a bunch of 80-year-olds
watching substitute host
Brian Kilmeade, saying,
"Tucker looks different now.
[ Laughter ]
He must've got that
eye-shrinking surgery."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"How much do you want us
to take them in?"
I don't know, a foot?
[ Laughter ]
Take, for example,
Fox's decision last week
to settle the Dominion
defamation lawsuit
for a whopping $787 million.
Sorry, $787.5 million.
And, real quick,
why isn't it a round number?
[ Laughter ]
Why did they have to .5
such a large amount of money?
What happened, did Dominion say,
"We want $788 million,"
and then Rupert Murdoch said --
[ As Murdoch ]
It'll be a cold day in hell
before I give you [bleep]
$788 million!
[ Laughter ]
And they said, "Alright,
how about $787.5 million?"
And he said --
[ As Murdoch ]
Oh, that's more than fair.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, yeah, we can make that work.
Nice doing business
with you [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, where --
Oh, right, right, right, right.
When Fox settled with Dominion,
the network's anchors barely
even mentioned the news on-air,
despite the fact that it was one
of the biggest media scandals
in recent history,
and, even when they did
mention the story,
they rarely went into specifics,
like when Fox personality
Howard Kurtz declined to say
the amount Fox had agreed
to pay,
despite the fact the lawyers
for Dominion
had already publicly announced
the exact number.
-Dominion had sued Fox,
charging that the network
damaged its reputation
by reporting on false claims
that its machines
were, somehow, stealing votes
from Donald Trump
and flipping them to Joe Biden,
citing internal messages
that key figures at Fox
did not believe
those conspiracy theories.
Fox said in a statement...
[ Laughter ]
A Dominion lawyer gave reporters
a dollar figure for the segment,
but I have not been able
to independently confirm that.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't independently
confirm it?
I don't know, maybe ask around.
You work there.
[ Laughter ]
Open your door.
Just yell down the hallway.
Or do a little investigating.
Like in the cafeteria,
is the coffee that was free
last week now...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sorry...
Ah, [bleep]!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[Bleep]
Anybody got $0.5 million?
[ Laughter ]
So, Fox viewers
have heard very little
from the alleged news network
they watch
about one of the biggest
media scandals in recent memory.
And the same thing happened
with the shocking ouster
of their top-rated host,
Tucker Carlson,
seen here realizing
he just got fired
or just being stoned
off his ass,
looking at a magic eye poster.
[ Laughter ]
Fox read one vague statement
about Tucker's departure
from the network during the day
and then, when Tucker's
old time slot
rolled around at 8:00 pm,
this is the only thing
fill-in host Brian Kilmeade said
about the situation.
-Hi, everybody, and welcome
to "Fox News Tonight."
I am Brian Kilmeade.
As you probably have heard,
Fox News and Tucker Carlson
have agreed to part ways.
I wish Tucker the best.
I'm great friends with Tucker
and always will be.
But right now, it's time
for "Fox News Tonight,"
so, let's get started.
-Man, when Fox cuts ties
with someone, they cut ties.
[ Laughter ]
That's the Fox News version
of rolling up someone
in a carpet
and throwing them
in the East River.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Even the Mafia's like,
[ Italian accent ]
Oh! Not even some cake
in the break room?
[ Laughter ]
Show the man some respect.
Tucker was their top-rated host,
their biggest star,
and now, they're acting like
he never existed.
His picture was plastered
on the Fox News headquarters
right across the street
from here.
I walked by it today.
It was an ad for Dr. Zizmor.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fox host Sean Hannity basically
did the same thing
during a segment
about ex-CNN anchor Don Lemon.
As his audience was cheering
Lemon's ouster,
Hannity briefly
mentioned Tucker,
but all he said was this --
[ Applause ]
-You know.
we're not talking about Tucker.
I don't really have
any details on it,
but he had a massive audience...
-Yes.
-...and has a huge following.
This guy had nobody!
-Yeah,
Tucker has a huge following,
among racist lunatics
and people who also want
to [bleep] the green M&M
[ Laughter and applause ]
and you don't have
any details on it?
His show was on
right before yours.
You chatted with,
you texted with him.
Is it possible they just
didn't tell Hannity the truth,
you know, the way you lie
to a five-year-old when
their goldfish dies?
[ As Hannity ]
I don't have any details
about Tucker.
All I know is he went
to host a show
on a farm upstate
with a bunch of other racists.
[ Laughter and ohhs ]
And I hear he's real happy.
[ Laughter ]
This is just a guess,
but I feel like they probably
do know why Tucker got fired
and they've expressly been told
to keep it to themselves.
I have no idea why he got fired.
Fox had no problem
with his cruelty, racism,
and paranoid
conspiracy theories,
so, I doubt he got fired
for that.
I mean, firing Tucker
for racism now,
after tolerating it for so long,
would be like canceling
"Sesame Street"
because you just found out
they were puppets.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm serious, dude.
I looked in Oscar's trash can.
There's a dude in there!
[ Laughter ]
If this gets out,
we're [bleep]!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
It would also be weird --
[ Laughter ]
It would also be weird
if he got fired
for being obsessed
with incredibly weird [bleep]
because that's also been
his thing forever,
whether it was sexy candy
[ Laughter ]
or eating bugs
or -- this is real --
testicle tanning.
-One of the biggest stories
of our lifetimes
is the total collapse
in testosterone levels
in American men.
-If you want to optimize
and take it to another level,
expose yourself
to red light therapy.
-Yes.
-And the Joovv
that we were using
in the documentary,
there's a massive amount of --
-Which is testicle tanning.
[ Laughter ]
-It's testicle tanning,
but it's also full-body
red light therapy,
which has a massive amount
of benefits.
And there's so much data
out there
that isn't being picked up on
or covered.
-So, obviously,
half the viewers right now
are like, "What?!
Testicle tanning?
That's crazy."
[ Laughter ]
But my view is, okay,
testosterone levels crash
and nobody says anything
about it -- that's crazy,
[ Laughter ]
so, why is it crazy
to seek solutions?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, the good news, Tucker, is
now, you have plenty of time
to pursue that, you know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just grab grab a book,
head to the beach,
unzip your khakis,
pull them out, and enjoy
all that newfound testosterone.
[ Laughter and applause ]
By the way, what's crazier,
that Fox News
abruptly parted ways
with their top-rated anchor
or that their top-rated anchor
did an entire special report
on exposing your balls
to red light therapy
[ Laughter ]
to increase your sperm count
and they were just fine with it?
Also, I don't need some fancy
red light machine.
Just dip your dong
in a toaster.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hell, stuff your junk
in a microwave,
put it on defrost.
[ Laughter ]
Save your money.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, I love that even the dude
who's pushing this theory
knows it's better to call it
red light therapy,
but Tucker just jumps right in
to make it clear
what we're talking about.
[ Laughter ]
[ As McGovern ]
What's interesting
about red light therapy --
[ As Carlson] Testicle tanning?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Is that the testicle tanning?
Because all my questions are
about testicle tanning.
[ Laughter ]
[ As McGovern ] Yeah, no, yeah,
it's just it's your whole body.
[ As Carlson ] Yeah,
but it also does the testicle?
[ Laughter ]
Also, I'm no testicle expert...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sal's words!
[ Laughter ]
[ Claps ]
[ Applause ]
I read --
Let me just say.
[ Cheering ]
This is the fourth time today
I've read this
and it's the first time I've
realized I'm just going like,
"Also, I'm no testicle expert."
[ Laughter ]
If there's one thing I know...
Also, you guys --
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering and whistling ]
I'm definitely going to be doing
one of those weird daytime ads,
like at CNN,
where it's just like,
30 years from now, an old
Seth Meyers is going to be like,
"I'm no testicle expert...
[ Laughter ]
...but I know
when something's wrong."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, you guys, I'm --
I'm no technical expert,
but does --
does red light actually make
your sperm count go up?
Is that what happened to Kramer
in that episode
about the chicken restaurant?
[ Laughter ]
[ Electricity buzzing ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Seinfeld ]
Did you hear?
Kramer's training --
Kramer's tanning his testicles.
[ As Elaine ]
Well, Puddy's tanning, too.
[ As Seinfeld ]
Puddy's a tanner, Kramer's a --
everybody's a tanner.
[ As George ]
That's it, Jerry!
I'm tanning, now, too!
[ Laughter ]
[ As Seinfeld ]
Why tan your testicles?
You're already nuts!
[ "Seinfeld" theme sting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Dear diary, it went great.
[ Laughter ]
Now, there's obviously been
a lot of speculation
over what, exactly,
happened here,
given that Tucker was such
a dominant presence
at the network.
Tucker himself was reportedly
blindsided by the news
and informed of the decision
just minutes
before it was made public.
The Wall Street Journal
reported that...
Fox couldn't have cared less
when Tucker was saying vulgar,
offensive stuff on television
about other people,
but when he said it in private,
about Fox News executives,
they were suddenly outraged.
It's like when you go see
a [bleep] stand-up comic
who spends the entire hour
roasting people in the crowd
and you laugh and laugh,
until he points at you and says,
"Hey, check out this idiot.
Looks like he stuck his face
in the testicle tanner,"
[ Laughter ]
and then you're like,
"Whoa, whoa!
That's not fair.
It's called red light therapy.
I heard about it on the news!"
[ Laughter ]
But Fox News was apparently
prepared for the possibility
that they might, one day,
have to part ways with Tucker
because yesterday,
Rolling Stone reported
this truly insane story...
Fox reportedly...
Holy [bleep], his own employer
was collecting dirt on him.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I can't imagine
if NBC ever did that to me.
"Hey, Meyers,
you better watch out.
We got a picture of you
in a chicken suit
next to Donald Trump
and we're going to send it
to Page Six."
Well, too bad, fellas.
That was already on TV.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Simpler times, you guys.
Simpler times.
Tell you this, though --
if I ever find the guy
who wrote that sketch --
It was me?!
[ Laughter ]
Also, if you're an employer
collecting dirt on an employee,
but you're not doing
anything about it,
unless you need it for revenge,
that speaks badly of them
and of you.
That's not how HR
is supposed to work.
[ Laughter ]
When we did our HR training here
at "Late Night,"
I don't remember anyone saying,
"And just remember,
we'll be keeping a blackmail
file on all of you."
[ Laughter ]
This is the state
of the MAGA movement.
It's an abject failure
and now, they're all
devouring each other.
They were
at each other's throats
after losing in 2018, 2020,
and 2022;
they're bickering and fighting
with each other in Congress;
and now, their leading
propaganda network
is navigating a messy split
from their former leading host.
After all these years,
I think we deserve
to just sit back
and watch these people
kick each other in the...
-Testicle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This
has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]